hey everyone do you know a Cyber attack
cost organization an average of 1.5
million dollars per attack the
importance of cyber security cannot be
understated in today's market by almost
all business passes through the internet
in some capacity or more so needless to
say trained cyber Security Professionals
are very high in demand which let's
simply learn to curate free scalar
courses that beginners in this domain
can take up and get started completely
self-paced and designed specifically for
job placement there are a variety of
courses in cyber security that can help
you take the next step in your career in
this video we will provide a cyber
security roadmap for 2023 but before we
begin make sure you subscribe to our
channel for more videos like this and to
stay updated with the latest trends the
first thing to acquire are basic
computer skills usually the relevant
computer skills and systems knowledge
necessary to work your way around
hundreds of platforms while computer
science degree is highly profitable and
helpful when starting in this domain
people from non-technical backgrounds
can also work in cyber security if the
train themselves in basic Computing
skills and number two networking skills
are essential since a lot of the work
will revolve around wireless access and
network security protocols with
everything going Wireless networking
skills and particularly Wireless
networking should be the next step in
your journey you can check out the link
for the Skiller person Internet Security
and other network security related
courses in the description box below
after polishing your networking skills
the third obstacle should be getting
your knowledge of Linux operating
systems to above average standards most
scanning tools and exploit Frameworks
run exclusively on Linux based
distributions like Kali Linux and parrot
security making it an absolute must
before moving forward
a course on the basic introduction to
Linux will get you up and running in no
time after which you can check the
ethical hackers for beginner courses to
further sharpen your skills basic
scripting skills should be the next step
since developing and combating exploits
will require some programming skills
while not mandatory these crypto skills
will help you modify exploits that can
later be used to secure infrastructure
moving on you must learn the basics of
hacking from scratch before moving on to
practice Labs or certifications the
ethical hacking for beginners course
will cover all the necessary tools to
begin your hacking career thanks to
detailed explanations on networking
cryptography and database skills
websites like hack the box and try hack
me a virtual Labs that function as
targets for ethical hackers practicing
their craft
as a cyber Security Professionals
practicing these rooms can help you stay
updated with the latest and most complex
tools available to penetration testers
today now regarding a professional
certification that can help you grow
further in this domain you have two
options the oscp online course can be
completed at your speed and schedule it
covers penetration testing tools and
methodologies through Hands-On practice
the program teaches the skills and
mindset needed to be a successful
vulnerability researcher and a cyber
security analyst the pnpt exam or the
Practical Network penetration test
certification is a one-of-a-kind
vulnerability scanning certification
exam that evaluates a student's capacity
to perform a networking penetration test
at a professional level you can thus
visit the officials Club website to
learn more about the Technologies you're
interested in and the free online
courses offered there this causes a
selfie is reduced taught by subject
experts and you can watch these videos
as long as you want and earn a
completion certificate at the end of it
the links for all the courses mentioned
above will be in the description box
below so that brings us to the end of
our video on the cyber security roadmap
for 2023 we hope you found this video
informative and we recommend you leave
your doubts and thoughts in the comment
section below thank you so much for
watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here